[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW SCHWARTZ:
Welcome to MLAI231,
A Glimpse into CBS
Interactive's AI/ML Group.
My name is Andrew Schwartz.
And I'm a product manager
for Video AI at Google Cloud.
And today, it's my
pleasure to introduce
Adam Leary and Rob Harrigan from
CBSI's Applied Machine Learning
Group.
And we're excited to
have them walk you
through their GCP journey.
As a brief introduction,
at Cloud AI,
our mission is to
help enterprises
transform their business
with the power of AI.
We do this by
offering a set of AI
building blocks, such as
our pre-trained models,
as well as autoML
products, so they
can add human-like capabilities,
like sight, language,
and conversation to
your applications.
Over the course of the last
year or so, it's been a pleasure
and it's been amazing
experience working with CBSI
as they've started to use
some of these applications
and apply them to two
of the most common media
entertainment challenges.
Starting last year, they had
zero services built on GCP.
Yet with a really small team
of just 7 and 1/2 people,
they've been able to build
two great AI services
that they can then
use to power and help
transform each of CBSI's 38
different content brands.
And with that, I'd like to
pass it over to Adam Leary
to continue with this story.
ADAM LEARY: Thanks, Andrew.
Good morning, everybody.
I would like to cover today--
I'm going to try
to pack a lot in--
a little bit of background.
So I think it's really important
to understand the context
from which the team emerged to
understand our path to product
development.
So a little bit in the
background and the motivation.
I'll give you a little
bit better understanding
of where we sit as a group
within CBS Interactive
and what we have to work
with in terms of data,
and the motivation center on
why we use the Google Cloud AI
building blocks.
Then we'll move on to building
products on Google Cloud
and review our main
product components,
and dive into a few of them.
And then we'll go into a
little bit of a functional
overview of the architecture
of our components,
as well as a brief look at
the content processing system
that integrates with
the Cloud AI products.
And then Rob will go over
our hybrid recommender system
in more detail.
And then we'll wrap
up with the business
impact of these
product components
and a brief look at
what we're doing next.
So as I mentioned and
as Andrew mentioned,
we're a small team that is part
of a larger central engineering
group within CBS Interactive.
So that means we work across
all of our digital brands.
We started from
scratch on Google Cloud
January 2018 with no
systems to migrate.
So it's sort of a wonderful
feeling in some ways.
The expectation is that
we demonstrate our value
to the brands--
we meet their product
KPIs, for example--
and compete with other vendors.
So outside competitors that come
into our brands and say, hey,
we offer this
brand this service.
So we were able to integrate
with services for brands
like CNET and CBS All Access.
So inspired by the nautical
theme of Kubernetes,
we embarked on our own voyage.
So this theme of Kubernetes also
inspired our own product names.
So you'll sort of see
those show up as well.
So the first question was
really, where to start?
It's a classic
question, of course.
And you can do so many
things in this space.
You really can sort
of overwhelm yourself.
So to go from zero
to production,
we had to consider our AI
business model, essentially,
which is the following thing.
So opportunities.
So what's the opportunity?
So consumer
expectations are very
high in terms of how
they interact with video.
And so the business benefit
of building recommendations
is also very high.
So we also saw a lot
of growth potential
in deepening our
own understanding
of our own content
across our brands
for the entire organization
and for our marketing teams,
product teams, sales,
search, ads, you name it.
So we call this approach
content awareness.
And our own
competitive advantage
is the data, the content, and
our own ability to get to it.
And also with enriching
content understanding
and recommendations, we took
that as our starting point.
And as I mentioned, the
barrier for data and content
was much lower for us.
So we took advantage of that.
So who are the consumers?
So who needs this?
Who needs these things that
we're trying to build out?
So one was internal teams.
First of all, starting
with ourselves.
So sort of like a good chef,
you keep tasting your food
as you make it.
So you'll see a little
bit of this later.
Our consumer-facing customers
were our brands, essentially.
Also, integrated marketing
teams and our ad teams as well.
So for example,
our marketing teams
want to send relevant
materials to the right users
to let them know about the
latest show on All Access.
So we can help them
make that happen.
In terms of policy and process
for our business model,
if you will, we as
a team really needed
to orient ourselves
to Google Cloud.
So a lot of us had not worked
on Google Cloud at that time.
So we were learning new
technology as we went.
We also-- some of
us were learning
principles of distributed
computing, even basic DevOps.
We're still amateurs at
DevOps, but we have to do it.
And getting our own
CI/CD service out.
So we also needed
to sort of reorient
our partners, the people
we work with internally
to deploying living
features, as I call them,
that require a level
of experimentation
to be successful.
So then how do we build it?
So applied is in our name.
So we essentially start with
Cloud AI building blocks
and do transfer learning.
And our own success
criteria were twofold.
One where our own product KPIs.
So when we deliver a service to
a brand, what are their KPIs?
We try to match those.
And then our own model
benchmarks for our own services
internally.
So as I mentioned,
what's the motivation?
Well, we have a lot of
wonderful content to work with.
So videos, articles, images,
like in image galleries,
podcasts.
And we have access to
them from our brands.
So in order to build a really
good recommendation service,
we needed to enrich what we
know about our own content.
There's a little nod to our
new show, "The Twilight Zone."
So we have a little
sample of content
here to give you a
flavor of what we have.
Gaming, tech news,
news, entertainment.
A lot of events get covered
as well, live events.
So back to how we build it.
So with the Cloud
AI building blocks,
we essentially said,
what we're going
to do is we're going to use
their services to get us going.
And then once we
get going, we'll
start to build our own in-house
solutions on top of it.
So this essentially
comes down back
to sort of a classical
approach to transfer learning.
So we viewed using Google Cloud
AI, like video intelligence,
vision, natural language,
as a type of transfer
learning where we're trying to
get achievable representations
in the model sense.
Time to learn is reduced for
us with a very small team.
And then it's going to
increase performance
for all of our
downstream services,
because we don't have
to think on that piece.
Because it really didn't
make any sense for us
to start from scratch
with some of those models
that Google Cloud AI handles.
So we took it from there.
So speaking of time, the proof
was in the production for us.
So this is just a sample
of some of the things
that we delivered
on those timelines.
So also, to give you a sense
of where we are right now,
here's a glance at what
the world looks like.
So the values aren't
really as important for me,
but it's really seeing
what we're combining
across CBS Interactive.
And it's really the fact that
we have a living system now
in production.
And we're able to
code, deploy, manage,
and deliver with a group
of 7 and 1/2 people.
So let me dive in a little
bit to our product components.
So as I said, we started
with this initial idea
of content awareness.
So roughly speaking,
we divide our world
into three product
classes, or components.
So first is content awareness.
So this is our service that
interacts with the Cloud AI
APIs, video intelligence,
vision, et cetera,
as well as data from our own
content management systems
and other important data APIs.
The second area of product is
what we call video services.
So these are built on top of
the first service, content
awareness.
So for an example, automated
captioning for our video
on demand, processing
live streaming as well,
doing object detection
on live streams,
bounding box, and entities
as well, automated clips,
thumbnails, and story adjusting.
And we'll talk a little bit.
And I'll show you a few little
examples if all goes well
in the video piece.
And then the third
class, of course,
is recommendations and search,
which Rob will talk more about.
So how do we architect for
all these products solutions,
especially starting
from zero and kind
of going as you go and implement
all the Cloud AI products?
So what I have here
for you is what
I like to call a
functional infrastructure.
And I call it functional,
because I really
mix architecture and services
for the purpose of showing you
how we process content.
So a lot of our other components
aren't represented here,
but I wanted to make
it easy to read.
So working from the bottom up
is a way to look at this setup
here.
So let me explain a little
bit about the color scheme.
So the blue layer
are the media icons,
which obviously are the pieces
of content that do not live
within our own team system.
The pink layers
are on Kubernetes.
The green-- excuse me.
The purple layers is
our storage layer.
The green layer on top are the
Cloud endpoints, so our APIs.
The gray layer is a messaging
queue and monitoring.
And the dotted box, of course,
represents the Cloud AI
services that we use.
And I'm also showing that we
make heavy use of the Service
Management API as well.
So let me walk you through
a really quick example
of how this might work.
So an editor might
finalize a video
for encoding in our
content management system.
So Trawler here on the bottom
will find that piece of content
and say, hey, this is new.
Send that off to
our content workers
to start the job of interacting
with the Cloud AI services.
And then bring back
the information around.
Is it ready yet?
And also starting to
store off the results.
We also then will use
Pub/Sub to emit messages
to our other services to
say, hey, this little bit
of information is now ready.
Go do your thing.
And a little bit of a
infrastructure call-out
for Kubernetes, as it really
aligns with our design
principles of immutability
of services and declarative
configuration for our
system, and allows
us to grow and scale quickly.
So let me dive a
little bit further
into the content awareness
architecture, where
we're using video intelligence.
So going from left to
right here, what we do,
obviously, is we're tapping into
our various video feeds built
by our own video tech teams.
So we'll handle a couple
of different formats;
video on demand and live stream
often in the form of HLS.
And then we also will handle
when our content management
systems have updates
or depublish something.
So that's our DataOps
bit, as I call it.
And then we'll
track the operation
via the Service Management API.
It's very important when you
have longer video content
to really make heavy use of
the long-running operation
to understand when
that process is
going to be complete so that
systems aren't left waiting.
And then what we'll do
is we'll gather what
has been called by the service.
So that might include for video
intelligence getting the shot
change information, segment
level labels, frame level
information, and
entities if needed.
Whatever is needed.
So what we do--
so in my Where to Start
section, I mentioned customers.
So one way we address this need
to make our work come alive
is in a web app.
So this is where we're
eating our own dog food.
So all the APIs we've
built, we put it
all into our own web app.
So what you're
really seeing here
is the output of some of the
services that I just mentioned.
So we have the video on
the Aston Martin Red Bull
simulator, racing simulator.
And as it steps through,
the shot changes
have been detected.
It updates the top
level shot entities
that we've also detected.
And on the right-hand
side there, you
see three little
tiny video clips.
Those are the output of
one of our video services,
which I'll show you a little
bit more about in a minute.
And you also see, of
course, the output
of the speech
transcription, where
we've done a lot of
extra post-processing
to make the captions actually
look and feel really nice.
So let me go on to one of the
video services I mentioned.
So this one we call Splice.
So let's say we have a video
about a Mars helicopter, which
is pretty compelling to me.
So what we do is we
treat all of our videos
as essentially a type
of narrative discourse.
So they're all
some sort of story.
It doesn't matter
where it comes from.
And then we'll break that down
into its foreground information
and its background information.
And foreground and
background has a lot
to do with how a
narrative goes forward
and how we understand
narratives.
So let's say we have
this video clip here.
This is what the whole
thing looks like.
And WTF, by the way,
means Who's The Future.
So don't think I'm
trying to fool anybody.
So you get a sense here.
This is the clip.
So now we'll have to take a look
at what Splice is looking at.
So Rob, if you could
play that first one.
You can play the Splice too.
So what you have here
on the right-hand side
is the output of
our Splice algorithm
gives you the top
three candidates
of what we would
consider to be the most
engaging five-second
clips from this video.
So what we'll do--
what we're charting for you
in our own web application
is the output.
Also, the scoring
for information
gain on the foregrounding
and backgrounding,
and other detail information
from the video itself.
And then these clips, these
cue points, if you will,
will get sent back
into our video system
to be picked up and
then used by the brands.
So as you can see
here, there's often
a lot of action
that gets captured,
often a lot of gist information
around what the video is about.
And that's the goal of
an animated thumbnail.
Essentially, it's to
capture your interest.
So now I'll turn it
over to Rob to go
into a little more detail about
our hybrid recommender system.
ROB HARRIGAN: Thanks, Adam.
So I'm Rob Harrigan.
I'm a senior machine learning
engineer with the Applied
Machine Learning Group at CBSI.
And my focus is on
recommendations.
So I want to dig into two
of our services today.
And those services are GenReco,
which is our Generalized
Recommender, and Admiral.
And now he's obviously the
leader of the recommendations.
He tells which
recommendation to go where.
So a little bit of motivation.
The goal of this is we want
baseline recommendations
for any brands that we're
ingesting and analyzing content
for.
So we have this great
content awareness built
on these Cloud AI API outputs.
And we want to be able to
generate some baseline content
to content recommendations.
And the fact that this is a
content to content similarity
recommender is a really--
it's a decision that
we made purposefully.
And that has a
lot of motivation.
One of which is that our brands
are content generation sites.
And so they're used
to delivering content.
And often, personalization
can add its own issues
with caching and delivery.
And we don't want
to introduce any
of that problem for a
baseline recommender.
Also, our recommendations
should be content agnostic.
We want to be able to take all
the different types of content;
images, image galleries,
reviews, articles,
all these different
pieces of content,
and recommend them
for each other.
They're all about some topics.
We can find which ones are
similar and recommend them.
And so we really
had three pillars
that we wanted to focus on
when we built this platform.
The first is flexibility,
like the Duck boat,
or as Adam might say,
the Schwimmwagen.
And so like a Duck
boat, we need to be
able to be on land and in water.
We need to be able
to handle lots
of rapidly changing business
logic with a small team.
We need to be
configuration-driven and be
able to select models
quickly and accurately based
on whatever the brand's needs.
Second, we need to be
powerful, like the Ferrari.
New content has to be
recommended quickly and slowly.
We have news cycles
that are very fast.
Think CBS News.
And we've got content that
has very slow news cycles,
like an iPhone review on CNET.
So this API will also
go on the front end.
And so it needs to
be fast and scalable.
It needs to be performant.
And we need to
support combinatorics.
We need to be able to
combine different sets
of recommendations together
dynamically at request time.
Lastly, it needs to be reliable.
We need to also be
a '90 Civic, right?
Since this is going on
sites' front ends directly,
we can't go down.
And again, we have
amateur DevOps.
We have a small team.
We need high availability
without a lot of DevOps.
So we want a separation of
powers between recommendation
creation and serving.
We want those two
to be separated
so that there's little overlap.
So first, flexibility.
By flexibility, I mean
deciding which recommendations
to choose or not choose based
on customers' business rules
and business logic.
They're going to give us rules
like users with five page views
today shouldn't get
trending, right?
Or everyone who lives in Poland
should get this recommendation
or not this recommendation.
And we fully expect these
rules to be complicated
and rapidly changing.
And we need to support whatever
the business can tell us
about a user, a
piece of content.
Any requests they
make to us, we need
to be able to make
decisions based on that.
And again, as a
small team, we need
to be able to make these easily
in a configuration-driven
environment so that
we can iterate rapidly
and don't have any downtime.
So we utilize YAML language.
And here's an example over
here under the Duck boat.
So you can see we've
got three recommenders.
And so the first recommender
would only be valid for users
that the site or the brand
tells us has at least three page
views and is authenticated.
The second one only valid for
users with at least five page
views.
Notice they don't have
to be authenticated.
The third one is for somebody
who really loves that site.
But the point is that these
variables can be anything
that the brand can tell us and
pass into us at request time.
The second pillar is power.
We need to be like the Ferrari.
And this really refers
to two different goals,
which work in harmony.
The first is that we need to
combine models dynamically
at requests time.
And the second is the rapid
ingestion of new content.
We need speed in our
time to recommendation.
So besides just being able
to select models, which
is what I talked
about in flexibility,
we want to build to
combine and backfill
models dynamically and in a
configuration-driven manner
at request time.
Support for combining
recommendations
really simplifies our
back end, because it
means that we don't
have to pre-compute
all possible combinations.
If a user is interested
in articles and video
on one of our
brands, say CNET, we
don't have to compute an article
and video recommendation set.
We can combine the article
recommendations and video
recommendations.
And this helps with
our speed of ingest,
because there's less things
that we need to pre-compute.
It also keeps our storage down.
And so obviously,
speed of ingest
is important, because
time that we're
generating recommendations,
those pieces of content
are not being recommended.
If you think about the
lifecycle of a piece of content
on one of our brands, like CBS
News, it could be very short.
And if we're taking hours
to generate recommendations,
we could completely
miss the time
where that piece of
content was relevant.
So we have support for a
number of combination types,
all dynamically at request time.
So the first is order.
So return this GenReco
model, and then a fallback.
Some say trending or something.
The second would
be an interleave.
So we're going to
alternate recommendations.
Or in the case of more
than two, round robin.
The third would be score.
So we have the model
scores stored in there.
So if the model
scores are comparable,
we can combine those by the
actual similarity score.
And lastly is weight.
So this would be, I want to take
this subset of recommendations,
but maybe order them by how
popular they are at the time
or something, right?
And so over here on the right,
again, we have an example.
So you can see that the class,
this is a Redis recommender.
And underneath in
these args, we can
see that we've got two data
sources coming from Redis.
So we've got a GenReco
model, which takes
input of site and content type.
And we've got a
fallback recommender.
And you can see that one
parameter sort of interleave
means that we're going to
return a GenReco, and then
a fallback, and then a
GenReco, and then a fallback.
But we can change
that one parameter
to order to return
GenReco and then fallback,
or score, to order them by
their similarity scores.
The last pillar is reliability.
Reliability is crucial for any
production recommendation API.
Our challenge is that our
team has limited resources
with only a few team members
and no dedicated DevOps staff.
And machine learning
iterates fastest and works
best in an environment
where experimentation
and collaboration is encouraged.
That oftentimes does not
coalesce well with stability.
So our engineers and
our data scientists
need to feel free to
experiment on back end systems.
Not too free, but pretty free.
And these recommendation
models, they
need to be able to create new
ones without fear of breaking
what's already working, right?
So this means that where we
create our recommendations
in the back end and where we
serve them in the front end
should be distinctly
different systems.
And you can work on
one and not the other.
And we can update business
logic on one and not the other.
And so this is done.
We should serve the
best recommendations
at any given time.
We're going to update
recommendations
as fast as we can.
And we give out the
best recommendations
that we know of at that time.
And Google Cloud Endpoints
helps us a lot here,
because it handles
authentication,
monitoring, as well as giving
us a central place for API
documentation, which you
can see here on the right.
That's our portal, which is
part of Google Cloud Endpoints.
And it takes your OpenAPI spec
and it gives some nice Swagger
documentation.
So let's take a look
at the architecture
and how this enables or
supports our three pillars.
So reliability really starts
with Admiral all the way
on the left.
You can see that the only
piece of our infrastructure
between our customer
and Redis, which
is where we store our
recommendations, is Admiral.
It controls what
models are selected
and what recommendations
are returned.
And it is the only choke
point for reliability.
Our ingest process, as
Adam has already showed you
a little bit,
starts with Trawler
all the way on the right, where
we source data into the content
awareness system.
And then we augment it with
the Cloud AI APIs and store it.
And then GenReco is
really three cron jobs--
remember, we're
amateur DevOps here--
and an auto-scaling
worker service.
So I'm going to go through
these steps in a logical order.
But it's important to remember
that in production, these
are all happening
simultaneously,
so that we can get content
in as fast as possible.
But the first step up top
there is data collector.
And so data collector
sources data
from our content
awareness system,
which is augmented with the
output of the Cloud AI APIs.
And it stores it into GenReco,
and formats it in a way
that we can use it.
GenReco submit is what
we call the next step.
And so if we tried to just
compare every piece of content
that we get with every
other piece of content,
it would be an
intractable problem.
It would require
lots of resources.
And most of those
comparisons would be useless.
So this first step is
a filter to identify.
Based on some
initial processing,
we identify the content that's
most likely to be recommended
for any given piece of content.
And then we submit those as jobs
to our auto-scaling workers.
Those workers then compute
the actual similarity metrics
based on our models.
And they can scale up when
content creation is high,
and scale down when there's
no content coming in.
The last step is
the most important.
And it's what we call GenReco.
And that's where we actually
create the recommendations.
So we pull all the
comparisons that have
been computed by the workers.
And we generate the
best recommendations
that we have at the time.
And again, this is all
running in parallel.
And at any given
time, we're just
getting the best recommendations
that we have at that time.
So how does this meet our goals?
It's flexible, because Admiral
can just serve JSON blobs.
We can change business
logic configuration easily
in Admiral.
It's powerful, because we
combine recommendations
in all these different manners.
We can have interleaving,
score, order, weight.
And all we have to do
is have models in Redis.
And we can combine
them dynamically.
We don't have to compute
every possible combination
that a customer might be
interested in, because we
have these other assets
that we can use to build it.
And this means that ingest
happens as fast as possible.
Content is constantly moving
through this pipeline,
and we're generating
some recommendations
as fast as we can.
And then we're continually
updating those recommendations
to make sure they're the best
that we know of at that time.
Reliability.
If any of these cron jobs goes
down, misses a run, breaks,
nothing happens.
Not exactly nothing.
Something happens.
But it's not that big of a deal.
We don't update recommendations
for those five minutes.
We have this buffer
time as engineers
to work on this back
end system where
it won't affect any
of our customers
who are being served
recommendations.
And so this
low-pressure environment
is really great for
our ML engineers
to be able to iterate rapidly
and create new models.
So you might be wondering,
boy, that's a lot of boxes.
Does it actually work?
I'm happy to say, yes.
In multiple tests,
we've shown an increase
in customer engagement of 14%.
So now I'm going to
hand it back to Adam
for the conclusions
and future directions.
ADAM LEARY: Thank you, Rob.
So before I kind of go into our
summary and future directions,
I hope that you
are starting to get
a flavor of the types of systems
on Google Cloud in general
that we're starting to use
and some of the decisions
that we made along the
way, which, of course,
we're always going
to improve as well.
But what I would like--
so we've sort of taken you
through our own stories,
so to speak.
So let's take a look a little
bit at some of the business
impact we're seeing as
we progress as a team
and what are some of
our next areas of work.
So what has really emerged
from our initial work
is a few things.
So visibility into our
own content across brands.
So what I mean by that is the
enrichment of the information
that we get back from Cloud
AI services on our content.
And this has also spurred
some new areas for us,
like we're now able to
search across videos, images,
all those entity objects.
In turn, this
visibility is beginning
to address sort of a pent
up demand, as I call it,
from our marketing teams,
to be able to rely on some
of these internal solutions.
And also what's
really important to me
is that we're now a
consideration for when features
are being developed for our
content management systems
and our video tech,
and our video players.
So our fellow teams have been
very supportive in our journey
and have been very strong
advocates of our progress
as well.
So at the onset,
I mentioned we are
tasked with competing
head to head
with a lot of outside companies
that come to CBS Interactive
and say, hey, let's do a PFC. So
we might be demoing their work
with their own brand.
So this is one of
the motivators for us
to have our own web
application as well,
to sort of do our own sales
pitches to these brands
as well.
And then say, hey,
we're happy to go
into a test with our
services and their services.
And we have done that.
So we're also able now to
provide some strategic options
for the company.
And in many cases, we
can do it much cheaper.
And so finally,
we're here to help
CBS Interactive as a
whole sort of embrace
the possibilities
of using ML and AI,
because it really is, as you
know if you work in the area,
it requires a bit
of a mind shift.
And so we also are aiming
to produce some tool kits
and packages that can be reused
by our other data science teams
and BI teams across the
company so that they reduce
their amount of initial work.
So what are we going
to look at next?
What are we doing now and
what are we working on?
So some of the things that we're
working on now and this year
are the following.
So I mentioned earlier in the
talk, video live streaming
enhancements.
So we are working on providing
some interesting features
on top of live streams.
So coming soon.
Second is we're in the
process of implementing
Kubeflow for our machine
learning pipeline management.
We've really reached
the maturity point
where we need to sort
of GitOps our pipelines
and allow them to be reusable
by our ML engineering team,
and even possibly other
data science teams.
Another area that's
really important for us
that we're exploring is GANs--
so Generative
Adversarial Networks--
for recommendation simulation.
So since we're sitting as
a central team among all
these brands, we're
often ready to go,
and we're waiting for the brand
to do their implementation
of our API.
So instead of just having that
be wasted downtime, what we'll
do is we'll create some GANs
that simulate user behaviors,
have it hit our own APIs, and
continue to tune the models.
We're also working
on stacked embeddings
within the hybrid recommender
that Rob went over.
So one of the great ways
that it was designed
is it allows us to add many
different, what we call, flows.
And so each of
those flows can be
a different stacked embedding.
And we're starting to
do our own benchmarking
against other systems
so that we can continue
to monitor its
behavior and meeting
our own expectations, as well
as the product expectations.
And then another area
that we are working with
is using AutoML Video and
AutoML Entity Extraction
for harnessing some of the
organizational knowledge.
And let me explain
what I mean by that.
So for AutoML Video,
we'll use that
for a secondary customization.
So as we get information in
from the initial Cloud AI,
like video intelligence
labels at the frame level,
and get the web
entities, we'll often
need to tune them for
certain brand use cases,
because it's a particular
person or brand
name might be very rare and
hasn't really been seen.
So it gets mislabeled.
So we'll use AutoML
Video to sort of do
a secondary
post-processing update.
And then we'll inject
that back into our system
to keep improving it.
And with the entity
extraction, that's
also going to have a similar
function within our systems.
[MUSIC PLAYING]